the executive program for growing
companies aims to build a stronger
structure for companies to grow to
increase the aspirations of the people
on the program that they can grow faster
they can grow stronger and they can grow
in a more sustained way each of the
executives brings what is called an
executive challenge I came to this
program because we are having plans to
grow our company more than three or four
times within the next three or four
years Stanford is the premier
institution for Entrepreneurship I
decided to come to you VGC because of
Stanford being well known entity within
the Silicon Valley EPG see is a
multi-faceted learning environment the
professor's developed the frame that
gives them a much deeper understanding
about how applicable those frameworks
are in some areas and not in others the
most inspiring tools and frameworks that
I've picked up for the ones talked about
it come to opportunities of strengths
and strategy the professors are
extremely extremely knowledgeable they
take it to a level where you can go back
to your country and your companies and
have to build it we have an unrivaled
set of senior executives all around the
world coming to the program
and we maximize the opportunities for
those executives to interact with each
other the program gave me new energy and
gave me a broader focus to take back and
distill that upon my important
this is definitely the place to be